foreign
[Music]
I work in cancer research where I lead a
computational team that solves
challenges in drug development but
that's not what I'm here to talk about
like many of you I'm really excited to
be here learning about ml Ops and tidy
models and quarto and all those things
and I think those are all great skills
that help you be good at your job
however I want to talk to you about a
skill that I think can help you be great
at your job and that is creativity and I
want to walk you through some of the
steps that I took in my creative process
for using R to help design a quilt and
hopefully that will extend a little bit
more into how you can apply these things
to get better enjoyment and fulfillment
out of your personal projects but also
your day job and so first I have to
start with a disclosure slide and my
disclosure is that I I'm actually not a
creative person or I like never thought
I was creative because creative people
look like this
they have like paint coming out of their
chest they have like light bulbs around
their head and they're genetically more
creative they have creative parents and
they just know how to solve problems and
ideas come to them from heaven
and I went to engineering school for
almost 10 years and I'm good at math and
I like it when there's a correct answer
and I can follow steps to get to that
correct answer however I'm in an
industry that requires a lot of
innovation and I looked around at the
people who were doing inspiring work
around me and whether those are people
that you know report to me or are people
who are influential in the field they
were very creative and so I you know as
a good professional I've been on a
journey over the last some years to
learn skills and to practice being more
creative and learning techniques to also
help teams and cultures be more creative
so now quilting
um for those of you don't know what a
quilt is it's a blanket and quilting has
been in practice for thousands of years
and what makes a quilt is that you have
three layers you have a top you have an
insulating middle layer and you have a
back layer and to quilt you connect
these layers together usually with red
and this can be very decorative it's an
art form
and personally I got really excited
about making quilts as art and
particularly the modern quilting
movement oh before I say that I just
want to put this in R terms that
everyone can understand quilting it's
just fabric you cut up you sew together
and then you sew it together again okay
so back to Modern quilting
um this is an example of a beautiful
modern quilt it has these organic shapes
made out of fabric this one I also love
extremely different but it has this
beautiful composition that draws your
eye around the frame
quilts can also play with color like
this example which is really challenging
to do given that you don't have every
color in the rainbow available to you in
fabric
quotes can also have political messages
or quotes can be personal like this is a
self-portrait someone made in fabric
so I was really excited about this and
that brings me to the prerequisite the
prerequisite is that you are excited
about your work
um I don't think you need to be the most
experienced person
so I started quilting at the beginning
of 2021 I bought a sewing machine a
little over a year ago but I'm not going
to let that stop me doing something
interesting if I'm excited about it
so the first step in my creative process
is to come up with too many ideas I'm
somebody that I like to come up with one
idea and then execute the crap out of it
like don't keep thinking about other
things but my new method is that I try
to come up with more ideas than I think
I need I have an idea quota where I come
up with 10 ideas 40 ideas 50 ideas and
then from that you end up with new ideas
that you had never originally thought on
day one and also takes you in directions
that lets you better curate your ideas
and what I end up doing with this
project was coming up with a solution
where I could fuse two domains
and I had just taken a drawing class and
I learned about the concept of two-point
perspective
two-point perspective is a way to make a
3D visualization in two Dimensions uh
like these cuboid shapes and I also know
about R and I thought well I'm really
excited about the things that are
happening with generative art using R
could I create some sort of landscape in
this way a 3D 2D production of a 3D
landscape using R using something like
geome polygon
and so with that I was really happy with
that idea and I started to go forward
uh so step two was I did a lot of
improvisation so I can start to learn
how could I make this visualization in R
how could I mess around with the
dimensions how many shapes I wanted the
size of these uh the overall aspect
ratio the colors
and then I had to do a lot of research
because the fact is that the design that
I had chosen is not easily convertible
to fabric which is not something that I
had planned for so I had to come up with
some techniques that would allow me to
construct my design in Fabric and that
is where I want to talk to you a little
bit about a technique I really like
which is called Foundation paper piecing
it's a little bit of a rabbit hole I'll
go down with you so this is a technique
where you create a design and you print
it on a piece of paper so you have a
design like this and you actually
sequentially sew fabric to that design
so this is what the back would look like
and then the front looks like this and
this is an amazing technique because it
allows you to do very very precise
piecing of fabrics together those lines
are all perfectly parallel you can have
very very small pieces and This lends
itself very much to the technique and
the design that I wanted to make
but there's a problem in that this
technique also imparts a new geometrical
constraint and the type of a design you
can create
so you can only add one piece of fabric
at a time and you can only add one seam
at a time which seems simple but it does
impose a constraint on the amount of
design that you can do
so for something like my design I'm in
trouble because this is not Peaceable
this design with this y Junction in the
middle I cannot do because I would have
to add two pieces of fabric at the same
time it doesn't work
so the way that people who design these
patterns work is it's basically like a
Sudoku puzzle it's all done by hand
where you look at this and I say well I
can't do this in one block so I'll split
it into two
and then I have to design where my seams
will go and then I also have to
determine the correct order because if I
don't add these pieces in the correct
order it won't work
and I really thought a lot about okay
well is there a way I could use r or
some other you know framework to help me
do this and I found a wonderful paper
that was published just last year by
Mackenzie Leake and others at Stanford
University which actually gets into the
mathematical foundation for doing this
and I really recommend if you're
interested to go ahead and read this
paper they've also got some YouTube
videos and even a web app that you can
use to help design your own designs and
so I don't really want to talk about
graph Theory although I do a little bit
which is that these designs are then
represented as hypographs where each
piece is a node in the graph and each
seam is an edge and this allows you then
to determine if your design is Peaceable
and also automatically derive the order
that you would add the pieces it's
really cool
so if we take a complicated design like
the one I made of the r logo on the left
that's actually four pieces and I can
represent them as four graphs and from
that I can determine that my design was
good because it was Peaceable and also
the order that I need to add the pieces
so that was great I'm good
except for now I have to make the quilt
and execution is a really hard part of
creativity because if you just have a
lot of ideas and you don't actually
follow through and finish them that's a
problem
so I started to work my sewing machine
and I I worked on it for a while and one
of the things that I think is really
helpful as part of a creative process is
to seek advice or collaboration so here
I actually went on quilting Reddit of
course that exists and I posted my quilt
and asked you know somebody give me some
ideas here I'm kind of stuck and people
were really generous they they gave me
these schematics back like Hey try this
try that which was fantastic
another thing that is part of executing
is that you're going to make mistakes
and the interesting thing about a visual
art like quilting is that your mistakes
are visceral and they're hard to hide
so in my git repo I can kind of hide my
mistakes although I don't I usually
write like big mistake big mess clean
this up but when I have something
physical that mistake is there and I
think it helps you get better at making
mistakes because you can see them and
you can be like it's okay it's part of
growing and learning
okay and so then this is the other part
that's really hard is that you have to
share your work so I did bring this
quote with me I have to put this mic
down
okay
so I think
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for humoring me but I think
this is one of the first GG plots ever
made in fabric probably not the first
but one of the first
um but there is another step which is
that
oftentimes you find that the question
you were asking when you started is not
actually the most important question or
the right question that you should have
been asking and that definitely happened
here
um I started off and I thought like yeah
I'll just make a deplot and then I'll
make it in fabric that's the right
question and I came up with these other
ideas which are really interesting
research that I could actually be
performing as part of this process
everything from like how do I choose the
right colors how do I determine how much
fabric to order to how do I try to
design these blocks
um more intelligently so that's one of
the future work that I'm working on at
the moment for example the r logo is
really hard to make as a quilt it has
some curved shapes it has some Square
shapes really difficult to represent
that actually in fabric
so I could do something sort of naive
here I can create a pixelated design
which I think it's actually pretty cool
but it doesn't really look like the r
logo to me so I wasn't happy with that
so then I can do this which is just I
kind of mostly by hand generated this
pattern and I think that's great I think
it looks just like the r logo so success
story except if I wanted to go a step
further and have the code generate this
for me
um that's what I'm working on and if
you're a close Observer you can see that
this doesn't look right
um
you don't have to humor me it's not
right
um so but from this I am learning a lot
right there's a process here and I'm
learning interesting things and I think
it's leading in different directions
right I can take that kind of thing and
I can make a self-portrait of myself I'm
working on other approaches where I can
have code generate you know a design but
as well the fabric choices that you
could use
so now that I've described the process I
have to be honest with you
I didn't describe it entirely in that I
kind of made up the order for the
purpose of the talk I thought it would
be helpful to say like one two three
four five six but in reality that's not
the order that I did these things and
that's true with a lot of creative work
whether you're doing it for your day job
or for your art projects
generally it's a very non-linear process
which is something that I personally
struggle with because I would like it to
be a linear process with like a right
answer
but that's something that can help you
strengthen your work
okay
so
um I want to now talk about a couple
tortured metaphors that I've learned
from other people that I think apply to
my work in computational research and
hopefully also will resonate with some
of you and the kind of work that you do
and how you could try to be more
creative
um so this first example I learned from
a colleague of mine at BMS josestakowski
and the question is would you rather be
a pizza deliverer or would you rather be
a plumber
I'll let people think
okay what does how do you get pizza I
order pizza a lot and it's great I can
get on my phone I can say what toppings
I want how many pizzas and then I get
like a photo of the pizza on my doorstep
it's incredible right it works really
really well for food delivery but I've
also been on teams where I'm a data
analyst and I'm asked for things in the
same way somebody goes on and they order
a dated Pizza they say I need this
dashboard with these features with this
data and I don't think that's a very
effective way to do data work I don't
think that's a good way for you to get
insights from data
and it doesn't leave any room for
creativity or trying to get to what are
really the right questions you should be
asking so a slight iteration on that is
to think about a plumber so a plumber is
a subject matter expert right I have a
plumber come to my house and they talk
to me about what my problems are they
bring their own toolkit they have their
own expertise and they try to understand
really what my needs are and they work
on a solution that will meet my needs
okay
so if you don't like that one that's
fine I have another one
so this one is would you rather be a
detective or a criminal
oh and it's a trick question you
actually want to be both
um so this is actually one from Albert
Einstein and so this is about explaining
why science is so difficult
so if you take a detective like a
Sherlock Holmes there's uh murder's been
committed and you collect Clues and you
have hypotheses like it's a jealous
girlfriend it's a ex-colleague or
whatever and you you put together all
these Clues and then you discover like
oh actually it was a poisonous jellyfish
that killed the person
that's that's how a detective works
right but the key is that a detective
knows what crime they're solving the
problem is really well defined this
person's been murdered this has been
stolen I know how to solve it
but the difference is for a scientist
you have to also come up with the
questions
so in that way you have to commit the
crime and you have to perform the
investigation
and I find this is a really apt metaphor
for the work that I do because you have
to constantly be asking am I asking the
right questions is this the important
line of research that I should be
following and I think that's a really
really important part of doing science
that requires you to be creative
okay so to wrap those thoughts up I
would say
you should be a plumber you should also
commit science crimes
and I would also encourage you to think
about celebrating your mistakes and also
getting exposure to new ideas so I think
at meetings like this it's great to go
to talks that you might not think would
be interesting I would also encourage
you to find your local like our user
group Our Ladies group or Meetup Group
to try to attend talks and meet people
that you might not normally meet in your
day job
okay with that I have some
acknowledgments or resources if you're
interested in learning more about
creativity and this is also a work in
progress that I have and you might
recognize that that is geompoint
all right thank you
[Applause]
[Music]